acknowledged you are literally a robot
and that is bizarre but somehow oddly
arousing oh oh that's a giant thrusting
dildo I'm really glad if whoa whoa
ramming dildo incoming it's so cool I
put my faith is that Woody from Toy
Story
why is he hopped up on so many pills and
licking his lips what is hi oh you're
lovely I don't want to say you're
horribly ugly because I would go on a
tirade about how that is true for some
reason I have to defend myself mailer
than the male acid honest decisions oh
hey the man for relations with my boy Oh
pop top of the morning to you laddies I
put on Lube on my fingers and prepare
myself while it slowly with a moan the
beam of light is not where I was it's
where I'm pooping and somehow all just
popping backs oh my god I'm not
responsible for all of these deaths you
know I'm not gonna be labeled the murder
just because I'm rampantly booing off of
me up that baby caught a faceful that's
no good now I went out and I got some
fish hey Karen I'm doing my intro here I
love you baby but you gotta let me be me
it's not gonna work out if you keep
butting in like that
sorry about that Karen
- it does nothing it does nothing I'm
just horrible person murdering these
plants I had this look at that smile
what'll happen if I go into the ocean we
can do it ladies are you making fun of
me no that's just how I talk and I live
on a dirt farm I grow potatoes and
probably smell bad do you love me I
haven't brushed my teeth in 10 years ha
ha ha also my grandpa is coming back
from the dead and I live next to a
wizard tower remember lots of potatoes
if you date B oh come on
Wow good job there buddy
Wow good job again you're gonna get
sliced you're gonna fall really you're
not gonna get up from that it's all I
really want to do but I'm gonna do a
gent I'm not gonna do a gentle Emma
[ __ ]
yeah 420 poison my windows over my
neighbors have been his whole time
scream about poo
crap
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye